[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 164 of the weekly
"Google Cloud Platform" podcast.
My name is Mark Mandel.
And this week, I am very
excited to be joined
by the wonderful Jon Foust.
How are you doing, Jon?
JON FOUST: I'm doing good.
Pleasure to be on the
podcast for the first time.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, awesome.
So glad to have you here.
For people who
don't know you, do
you want to give people a
quick intro into who you are
and what you do at Google?
JON FOUST: Sure.
So my name is Jon Foust.
I am a developer advocate,
specializing in cloud gaming.
I mainly focus on a
lot of the GCP-Unity
integrations and helping
out with the Connected Games
Initiative that Google
and Unity have together.
MARK MANDEL:
Awesome-- fantastic.
So this week, I'm
also excited to have
another wonderful person
coming to join us.
Myles Borins is coming back
to talk to us about Node.js.
He last talked to
us back in 2017.
I actually went and had a look.
So I think there's probably
some new and exciting things
in that.
And then after that,
we have our question
of the week, where
I get to ask you
tough questions,
Jon, about the work
you've been doing,
connecting Google Cloud APIs
and working within Unity
and how you do that.
JON FOUST: It'll be fun.
MARK MANDEL: It'll be fun.
But why don't we get stuck
into some cool things
of the week, where we get
sucked into those other topics.
My favorite cool thing
of the week this week
is that Google Cloud Next 19's
Session Guide is now available.
So if you're familiar
with Cloud Next,
it's our big flagship conference
here in San Francisco.
It's big.
It's bright.
It's beautiful.
And we do a lot of talks
about all the things cloud.
So if you want to see what
some of the sessions are,
we have hundreds and hundreds of
sessions across infrastructure,
application development,
data management,
analytics intelligence,
productivity,
and collaboration.
Oh my god-- so much stuff.
JON FOUST: It's a mouthful.
MARK MANDEL: So if you
want to check that out--
yeah, it's a lot.
But there's hundreds of topics.
So check it out and
see what's going on.
Jon, what have you got?
JON FOUST: Sure-- so we're
introducing scheduled snapshots
for a compute engine persistent
[? disk. ?] So what it means is
that we have scheduled
automated snapshots on any time
[? info ?] of your liking.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
JON FOUST: So this means
that you can do every six
hours or every Monday.
And also what you can do
is-- we have scheduled
retention policies as well.
So that means you can actually
set it to actually delete
those snapshots every six hours,
every Monday, or every month.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
that's super cool.
That's really nice.
Speaking of doing regular things
to compute engines instances--
there's a new
solution that came out
called Reliable Task Scheduling
on Compute Engine with Cloud
Scheduler.
So Cloud Scheduler is the
thing we brought out--
I think it was several
months ago now--
for doing reliable, basically,
cron scheduling for items.
And there is a
solution here with code
that talks about how you can use
Cloud Scheduler, sending data
to Pub/Sub on a regular basis--
[INAUDIBLE] cron, basically--
and then reliably parsing
that or doing something or
some sort of operation on GCE
with that and making sure that
it works in a reliable way,
even if some of your
instances go down
or other things like that.
So if you're looking
to do something
along those sort of lines, you
can check out that blog post.
It's got diagrams and code and
all sorts of other good stuff
too.
JON FOUST: Another cool thing
that we have going on is--
one of our teammates
posted a blog post--
"How to make a self-destructing
VM on Google Cloud."
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
JON FOUST: What that actually
does for you is, like,
suppose that you have a VM
that's been running for a while
and you forget about it.
And you don't really
want to pay for it.
You can actually
have a startup script
that actually, once
you've started your VM,
automatically starts a
countdown for deletion.
So you can set it for
two hours, a week or so.
It's pretty awesome.
MARK MANDEL: This message
will self-destruct
as soon as you read it,
or something like that.
JON FOUST: Exactly.
After reading the blog
post, I felt like a GCP spy.
[SPY MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: That's fantastic.
Last but not least, we have
a new blog post that's coming
out, talking about our
AI-powered speech--
giving it more options,
lower prices, new languages
and voices.
So if you're looking to do
text-to-speech type operations,
now we have support for
seven new languages,
including Danish, Portuguese
in Portugal, Russian, Polish,
Slovakian, Ukrainian, and
Norwegian, and Bokmal--
if I'm pronouncing
that correctly.
There's also 31 new voices--
all sorts of good stuff.
So there is now a total of
21 languages and variants,
111 total voices, and 57
WaveNet voices as well.
Ooh!
So if you're looking to
create speech from text,
you may want to check out
some of those new features
that we have available.
JON FOUST: I'm definitely
going to build some cool things
with that.
MARK MANDEL: I bet you will--
awesome.
Why don't we chat with
Myles and go see what's
going on in Node.js land.
As always, I am
extremely excited to have
another of my favorite people
joining us on the podcast
today.
Myles Borins is coming to
talk to us about Node.js.
Myles, how are you doing today?
MYLES BORINS: I'm doing great.
Yesterday was my birthday.
And--
DIGITAL CHORUS: Happy birthday!
MYLES BORINS: --we
had a lot of fun.
And I'm in relatively
high spirits
and feeling quite
positive today.
JON FOUST: Yeah, it was
definitely a fun time.
I actually got to celebrate
with Myles last night.
[CELEBRATORY SWISH]
MARK MANDEL: Well,
happy birthday, Myles.
Happy birthday indeed.
MYLES BORINS: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Is this coming
on the podcast your birthday
present?
Is that basically
how this works?
MYLES BORINS: I didn't want to
put too much pressure on you.
But it's the highlight of
my day after my birthday.
MARK MANDEL:
Excellent-- excellent.
So I know this isn't your
first time on the podcast.
We did have you back in
2017 for episode 105.
But if people haven't
had the distinct pleasure
of meeting you, do you want
to tell us about who you are
and what you do at Google?
MYLES BORINS: I'm a
developer advocate at Google,
working specifically on
Google Cloud Platform
and more specifically
in our languages team.
I actually think we all report
up through the same manager.
That's fun.
MARK MANDEL: I think
we actually do.
JON FOUST: Yeah, we do.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's been fun.
[LAUGHTER]
MYLES BORINS: This could be
our weekly stand-up as well.
Within languages,
I focus on Node.js.
And I do quite a bit of work
with our various runtime teams.
So that's Cloud Functions, app
engines, serverless containers.
More recently, like in
the last couple weeks,
I've started digging into
Cloud Build quite a bit.
When I'm not working
directly at Google,
I do a lot of open source work.
I sit on the Technical
Steering Committee
of the Node.js project.
And I represent the
Steering Committee
on the Board of Directors
of the Foundation.
I also do standards
work at TC39.
And I started to do some
work at W3C and IETF as well.
MARK MANDEL: So not a lot--
just a couple of things.
MYLES BORINS: Yeah--
just a few things.
JON FOUST: Yeah, and you forgot
that you are very engaged
in the community, especially
meetups that involve food.
[CRUNCHING NOISES]
MYLES BORINS: Yeah, that's true.
I do run DimSum.js.
[GONG RINGS]
MARK MANDEL: I did not
know that was a thing,
but now I want to go
to that [INAUDIBLE]..
MYLES BORINS: Yeah, I used
to run the San Francisco one.
MARK MANDEL:
Excellent-- awesome.
So yeah, we did have
you back in 2017,
talking about all
the Node.js things.
But it's been a year or so.
So what's changed?
I'm sure there's stuff.
MYLES BORINS: There's a
couple different things.
One of the things that's fairly
new-- and I wanted to plug--
that I'm excited
about is Node.js.dev.
So Google has very recently
launched the .dev top-level
domain.
And as part of
launching the domain,
which has a number of stages
of access-- so if you really,
really cared about
getting a domain,
you could have gotten a couple
of days ago for $11,000--
I think it's now, like, $1,100.
JON FOUST: Oh my god.
MYLES BORINS: And by--
I think, it's Monday, it
gets down to about $150.
So I have a reminder
set for Monday.
[CHIME]
Hopefully, I can
get a couple I have
on my mind a little cheaper.
Then it goes all the
way down to $15--
will be regular registration.
But a number of different
partners as well as
individuals who own IP rights
got early access to domains.
And one of those
was Node.js.dev.
The .dev team reached out
to myself and Franziska
Hinkelmann, who is another
[? dev-reler ?] who focuses
on Node.js, asking if we'd
be interested in using it
for the Foundation.
And in six weeks of a sprint,
we put together a static Gatsby
website.
It is based on a
whole bunch of content
that the project's been
working on for a while.
It's a whole new slew
of getting started
documentation about hey, how
do I get started with Node?
What are some of
the basic concepts?
How do I even do a node?
And so it's a really
great starting place
for people who want to
learn about Node.js.
It's also an open source
project that's available
on GitHub/nodejs/nodejs.dev.
So if you're looking for a
low-barrier way to get started
in contributing to
the Node.js project--
if you like React,
if you like Gatsby,
if you like playing around with
websites and improving SEO,
there's lots of
different ways where you
can come in and get involved.
JON FOUST: Nice-- what can
we actually expect to see
on Node.js.dev?--
the landing page.
MYLES BORINS: So
there's actually
a bit of a history to the
content that ended up there,
which I think is kind of fun.
So we have the current
nodejs.org website.
And that has been around
for a number of years.
It's showing its age a bit.
And I think, around
a year to a year
and a half ago, a
working group spun up
around a website redesign.
And they've been doing this
super extensive redesign
of the whole site.
And as you can imagine,
when you decide
to just completely
replace something
instead of just doing
iterative change,
it takes a long time
to make something
that's feature complete
or to build consensus
around the features that
you're going to drop.
One of the things that
that team worked on
was this large slew of content.
There was a collaborator who--
their name is escaping
me right now--
but I'll dig it up and hand
it over to both of you,
so we can include it
in the liner notes.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MYLES BORINS: But someone
wrote all this amazing content
and donated it to the
website redesign group.
And it was to live on the
/learn page on that new site.
And when we found out that we
were going to get the .dev TLD,
one of the first things we
needed to figure out was, OK,
well, what content are we
going to even put there?
And it quickly came off as--
hey, actually, we have
all these wire frames
for the new, redesigned website,
including this one learn page.
And we have 70 to 100
pages of documentation.
Why don't we just do that?
And so we actually just
made was originally
supposed to be a single
route on the new page
into this one
specific landing page.
And it's possible that
we may just slowly
bootstrap more and more
features onto this page.
And it could eventually become
the new Node.js landing page
altogether.
But it may continue to just
be its own separate learning
resource page.
But Jon, to more explicitly
answer your question,
all of this is very
much up in the air.
And it's going to be very much
determined by who's showing up
and who's doing the work,
what work actually gets done,
what kind of consensus
we can build around it.
But the future is open.
It can be whatever the
people who are working on it
make it into.
JON FOUST: That's awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and it
looks like all the content
is all available on GitHub.
So if you want to go and edit
it, you can go play with it
all in there, if you wanted to
add or edit and do stuff to it.
MYLES BORINS: Yeah, and we
actually just added, today,
at the bottom of
the page-- it's just
an Edit on GitHub button,
which will drop you
right into the GitHub Editor.
And so it's all just mark down.
So if you see a
spelling mistake,
just scroll down to the
bottom of the page--
MARK MANDEL: Fix it.
MYLES BORINS:
--click that button.
You could send us a PR.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And I think you
were talking earlier
and you said there was some
Cloud Build integration
or something like that.
You did some integration there.
What's that all about?
MYLES BORINS: Yeah-- so
for those who don't know,
Cloud Build is a
product from GCP.
I have been, very
recently-- as of yesterday,
when I had an aha moment--
referring to it
as serverless ops.
But it's a really cool product
where, with a YAML file,
you can describe-- hey,
here's a container--
and then run this command
with the container
and set a series of steps.
You can then connect Cloud
Build to a particular repo.
And then you can trigger
particular YAML files--
like, Describe Builds
or Docker files--
on specific actions.
And those can either be
pushes to specific branches,
the creation of tags,
or pull requests.
And you can create
regular expressions
to filter them all, as well.
So you could be like,
hey, if a branch is
pushed that matches this--
so for example, one of
the things that we do
is deploy to Firebase
Hosting on a push to master.
So it auto-deploys with
continues integration.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
MYLES BORINS: And then the
other one that we have is
build and push to staging
on a pull request.
But one of the things that Cloud
Build has that's interesting
is--
we have it set up so that
it doesn't run automatically
when a pull request is opened.
A collaborator actually has
to put in a special comment.
And that will trigger the build.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I see.
MYLES BORINS: And the
reason for that is--
what gets neat with this is,
internally, in the IAM roles
inside of Google Cloud, you
can set specific IAM roles
to the build agent itself.
So for example, I'm using Cloud
Build to deploy to Firebase.
And all I had to do
was deploy a new image
that is meant to deploy
with the Firebase API.
And then I gave Cloud Build
itself IAM Admin privileges
over Firebase.
And now, whenever
it runs that script,
all of the credentials that are
necessary are already in-lined.
So I don't need to
inline any credentials.
And I can restrict or
add more privileges,
based on what the need are.
But this is part of
the reason to have it--
so that, for running
the build, you
need to have a comment
from a collaborator.
We went back and forth
on this quite a bit.
But it could be, like,
a resource attack.
If you just automatically
kicked it off
and then someone could
just, like, shimmy
in a bitcoin miner--
[DIGITAL CLING]
--which you don't
want happening.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh-- so
that's really interesting.
How have you got the
integration set up
between the GitHub page itself
and writing a comment there
and then, like, firing off
a build on Cloud Build?
Because they're not
hooked up that way.
MYLES BORINS: So this is
just built into Cloud Build
actually.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah?
MYLES BORINS: So
with Cloud Build,
there's a new thing
that's rolling out
publicly soon, where you
essentially click a button
to link the repo.
It links the pull request.
And using GitHub
event-based API,
it actually triggers an event,
which we handle internally
on every comment.
So it's actually
just a box you tick
when you're setting up the--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's cool.
MYLES BORINS: --pull request
trigger that just says,
do not run this trigger unless
someone explicitly runs it.
So we actually have
two different things
going on right now.
We have one check suite,
where Travis runs.
And Travis will run the build.
Travis will run the test suite.
And it will let us know
if anything's broken.
And then we can
trigger this other
build through Cloud Build.
And what it will do is
a compiles the site.
It builds it.
We have a single folder.
Then it uploads
that to GCS, using
the [? shaw ?] of the
commit as the slug for it.
And then it puts
a comment in that
says, hey, go to this link.
And you'll have a staging
version of the site.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MYLES BORINS: This just makes
it really easy for people.
When they send PRs,
we can kick off a
build, once we've reviewed
it and see that there's
nothing nefarious going on.
[EVIL LAUGH TRACK]
And at that point,
we have a link
that anyone can
go to and look at.
So people can review
it, even on mobile.
You never have to really
have an environment set up
to review it.
JON FOUST: It's awesome.
MARK MANDEL: That's super nice.
Actually, it sounds like Cloud
Build and GitHub integration's
improved since I
last looked at it.
MYLES BORINS: Yeah-- and
it's been really fun digging
into this as well,
because there's
all sorts of
unexpected edge cases
that I've been encountering.
And it's been really great
working with the Cloud Build
team.
They've been super responsive.
And they're really
interested in making
a best-in-class
integration here.
So it's been really fun.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And I know you do
a lot of stuff,
as well, the Node.js
Foundation side.
There's been some interesting
foundational work that seems
to have been going on recently.
You want to tell us about
what's happening there?
MYLES BORINS: I like
how you called it.
It's foundational.
[LAUGHTER]
So the Node.js Foundation
is a non-profit.
It's a 501(c)(6).
And it has this
mission of sponsoring--
overseeing the Node.js project
and the work towards it.
There's another foundation
in the ecosystem focused
on JavaScript, called the JSF.
It's the JS Foundation.
And they are actually both
under the Linux Foundation,
as where they were brought up.
And for a number of different
reasons, including-- hey,
there's two things, which one
do I support financially?--
we found that it was in the best
interest of all of the projects
to look into merging
the two foundations.
So last October, we
announced at Node Interactive
that we had an intent
to merge the Node.js
Foundation and the JSF into
one umbrella organization.
Some of the biggest differences
for the Node.js Foundation
itself was that there are
more than one projects in it.
Actually, Express and libuv are
under the Node.js Foundation
as well.
It was mostly built up to
support a single project.
And the top-level governance
of that project, the Technical
Steering Committee,
was chartered directly
from the board to oversee
everything in the open source
side of things.
There's a strong separation.
And I think we dug into
this in our last podcast.
But there a really
strong separation
between the technical governance
and community governance
and the financial governance.
So the board oversees finances.
They oversee certain
degrees of marketing.
But the board is unable to tell
Node Foundation-- like, hey,
put this person
on your committee
or, hey, land this PR.
We have a community governance
process that's set up.
We're openly governed.
And that's how things run.
And so one of the interesting
challenges here is--
the JSF has, I think,
15 or 20 projects.
I should know that number.
I don't know it off hand.
MARK MANDEL: Give or take--
MYLES BORINS:
Yeah-- give or take.
MARK MANDEL: 10%.
MYLES BORINS: But in
the merger, we now
are going to have a
structure where we
need to support many projects.
And so since October,
we have been holding
weekly open public meetings.
We've been broadcasting
them on YouTube.
And they're all saved.
And there's meeting
notes for all of them
that are on a GitHub repo--
GitHub.com/nodejs/bootstrap.
And this bootstrap committee has
been designing the governance
for the new foundation.
It started with a couple of
weeks of actually designing
the governance
for the committee,
so we could design the
governance for the foundation.
And once we reached consensus
on a process, it actually--
in a really amazing way--
unlocked this thing we had
never really considered before,
where the foundation itself--
we never really had a
process for how collaborators
could come up with new
processes or new committees
or new initiatives
that they wanted
to run within the foundation.
So the first thing we did was
actually design this process.
It's a proposal process.
It's based on how TC39 designs
the JavaScript language.
But there's three phases--
technically four, if
you consider stage 0.
But it's like, hey, here's
an idea of something
we want to do-- is stage 0.
Stage 1 is, hey, here's a rough
shape of how we want to do it.
To get to stage 2,
you need to actually
have all the documentation
put together and agreed
upon by the community
that, hey, this is
exactly how we want to run it.
And at stage 2, it
goes to the board
or to whatever committee
will oversee it to approve
that, hey, we agree with this.
And then it moves to stage 3,
which means it's initiated.
So moving forward,
the Foundation
will actually have a whole
thing in place for people who
want to do new things with it.
The Foundation is being designed
with a top-level committee,
known as the
Cross-Project Council.
There'll be representatives
from various different projects
within the Foundation
itself on that committee.
And that committee will
be chartered by the board,
to oversee chartering
other projects,
managing budget, code
of conduct escalations.
We're actually looking at
having a foundation-wide code
of conduct.
And it's going to be
interesting finding the balance
because, in the same
way that we kept
a clear separation
between the board
and the technical project
and the Node Foundation,
we want to still maintain
a pretty clear separation
between the
Cross-Project Council
and the technical projects.
We don't want the foundation
itself dictating too directly
how projects should be run.
But with that being
said, we're pretty
opinionated about what it
means to be openly governed
and what makes healthy,
active projects.
So there are things
that will be necessary.
But we're trying to
find the balance there.
So like, you will have
to have a license.
It may have to be within
a subset of licenses.
But we're not going
to be like, you
must have the Apache license.
But it will be
like, hey, you must
have Apache or MIT or a GPL that
doesn't start with the letter
A or some combination of that.
We're also going to have
a strict code of conduct
that all of the
projects must adopt.
But then that introduces
interesting problems.
Like, if a project only
has 10 or 15 people,
how do we actually help
them maintain and enforce
that code of conduct,
if they don't
have the resources to do so?
So we're looking up spinning
up foundation-wide committees
to help with that.
And there'll be a number
of different places
where projects can come
in different progression.
So for example,
right now, when we
were doing the merger
of the libuv project,
then that's the underlying
abstraction of system calls
that's used in node.
That project is
healthy and active--
but don't have any interest
in working with higher level
governance or getting any sort
of marketing support or larger
financial support.
They just want to keep
the lights on and have
infrastructure support.
So we have a way that they can
come into the new foundation.
There's no expectation
of them having
to grow to do anything more.
It's a vendor neutral place
for them to keep their IP.
It's somewhere for
them to receive
the small amount of
resources that they need
and to just do their thing.
And they'll still be
empowered to come--
like, any member of any
project in the Foundation
will be able to
attend CPC meetings
and be able to participate
in consensus at the CPC.
But there will be a smaller
subset of voting members
that represent the impact
level projects, which
is, like, our top level.
I mentioned all these
different things
you need to be in
the Foundation.
There'll be even more guidelines
for projects that we're--
impact level that will have more
support and from the Foundation
itself.
I think I spiraled out there.
[LAUGHTER]
There's lots of stuff.
So I guess, in short, check
out that bootstrap repo.
All of the governance
has been designed
using that proposal process
that I was talking about.
All the proposals are
documented in there.
And you can read them.
You can see the history of
how we got where we are.
And if you are a member
of any of the projects
that are involved
in the Foundation,
you're encouraged to open a PR
and start engaging and changing
it.
Show up to any of the
meetings and participate.
We're trying to minimize
the amount of hierarchy,
but create enough
structure to empower people
to enact the change
they want to see.
JON FOUST: We've actually
shared a cab ride.
And I remember you giving me
the less long-winded version
of this.
And I can tell that you're
pretty excited about it.
[LAUGHTER]
MYLES BORINS: And this version
is still pretty abridged too.
We could probably do,
like, a two-hour podcast
of me talking just about this.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, my god.
JON FOUST: Definitely--
but Myles, I'm curious.
What does this actually
mean for developers?
MYLES BORINS: Foundations can
often be like a release team.
And it's one of
those things that you
don't notice until you need it.
And generally, when it's
in a place that really
is like, oh, my god, I'm so
glad I have this in place,
it's usually too late
if you didn't have it.
A good thing for
developers would
be-- like, any of the
projects that are inside
of this foundation, they should
know that resources, oversight,
and initiatives are in place
to help support that project
and make sure that
project is healthy.
Arguably, if any of the
projects within the Foundation
are not doing well,
that reflects poorly
on the Foundation and the
Cross-Project Council itself.
So I think that there is a
certain amount of comfort
that people could have in
knowing that the projects are
going to be maintained.
The other side,
too, is, if you're
a developer working
for a company
and that company, maybe, has
stringent open-source policies
or, alternatively, if you
want to be collaborating
on something, in general,
having the IP of an open source
project in a neutral body
that's a nonprofit significantly
helps organizations collaborate
together on these things.
So Node.js being inside of
this nonprofit in this vendor
neutral place to
store everything--
that allows companies like
Google and Microsoft and IBM
and Intel all to come
together and collaborate.
And I know at least
from personal experience
that some of the
organizations that I mentioned
would not put an entire
headcount or multiple
headcount onto a project if
it was owned by a competitor.
That's just not smart business.
So I think, also,
as a developer,
it helps you to maybe
contribute back,
depending on the company
that you work for
and their policies.
JON FOUST: Nice-- awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Nice, nice, nice.
What news have we
got about Node.js
on Google Cloud Platform?
Have we had any recent
updates or cool things
that have come out that you
want to talk about as well?
MYLES BORINS: Yeah-- absolutely.
There's a couple
different places where
you can run Node in our cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah--
maybe give people
a reminder of where you
can run Node in our cloud.
That's probably a
good starting point.
MYLES BORINS: One of
the obvious ones--
like, the old-school way of
running code in Google Cloud--
is App Engine.
And so we've got both App Engine
Flex and App Engine Standard
Support for Node.js.
We currently support
the Node.js 8 runtime
in general availability.
And then the 10 runtime is beta.
But I do believe
that we're going
to be moving 10 to general
availability in short order.
I don't have an
explicit timeline on it.
But sooner rather
than later might
be a nice way of putting it.
MARK MANDEL: That works.
MYLES BORINS: For Cloud
Functions, we support Node.js.
We support Node.js
in version 6 and 8.
Both of those are in
general availability.
And in a similar
short order, we're
looking at bringing out the
Node.js 10 runtime in beta
on Cloud Functions.
We also have this thing
that's being worked on.
It's kind of secret,
but not super secret.
Because I know I can
tweak the sign-up link.
But we have this
thing that we've
been working on called
serverless containers.
And that's totally a place
that you can run Node as well.
Arguably, you can
run anything that's
in a Docker container that
responds to something on port
80.
[LAUGH TRACK]
But it is a cool
place to put Node.
And one of the ways I like
to think about it too is--
all of these are
abstractions on themselves.
And I think something that
we're working towards and trying
to get out in the
Node 10 runtime
for Cloud Functions is
this idea that there really
isn't that much difference
between a container, an app,
and a function.
And a function itself is
built with containers.
And it just has an opinionated
way of running the code.
It looks a lot like Express.
But it's a little framework
that's built on top of Node
to make it easier
to run your code.
So if you're writing
code inside of a function
and then you hit this boundary
of, like, hey, working
within this one function
isn't really giving me
all the flexibility and
expressiveness that I need,
you can easily take that
and turn it into an app
and then deploy it to App
Engine and see similar billing
or similar functionality--
also maybe better
cold start times,
depending on what you're doing.
But if you hit the
edge of, like, hey,
this is the edge of what I can
do with App Engine Standard--
which is going to have faster
deploy times and it's more
managed--
you can move to Flex or
to serverless containers
and start using a
Docker container,
if maybe there's a native
module that we don't support
or there's something
that you need to do,
like spinning up
a certain binary,
or anything fancy
that goes beyond what
we offer in our base image.
One of the things
that I find really
empowering and important
to think about is--
there are containers all the
way down all of these things.
And so it's just
like, how much sugar
do you want in your cereal?
And how much do you want
things to be on rails?
I don't know.
I can come up with
some more idioms.
[LAUGHTER]
JON FOUST: Sugar in
your cereal's awesome.
MYLES BORINS: But really,
at the end of the day,
I guess functions also
have the advantage
of eventing right now.
So you can take some event
and tie it to a function.
So it's really easy
to have something
that puts a whole bunch
of things in a task queue
that triggers a Pub/Sub
and then triggers
a function in the background.
I like using these
sort of things,
like emailers or for
transcoding and stuff like that.
But overall, all of
these different things
have their uses.
And we can grow
with you, depending
on what you're doing,
how you're doing it,
and what you need to do.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah-- sure.
So Myles, what are the places
can we actually run JavaScript?
MYLES BORINS: So there are
a handful of other places
you can run JavaScript in
Google Cloud that's really fun.
And maybe you wouldn't
think about it.
You can run JavaScript inside
of any G Suite products
with Apps Script.
Apps Script is JavaScript.
And there's a new beta that
you can use to try it out
with the new V8 engine.
So if you've ever
written functions to--
like, edit your spreadsheets--
I'm actually using it right now.
We're managing a guest
list for a large event
that we're planning.
And there were some
queries that we
want to do that I
couldn't figure out how
to do that inside of Sheets.
So I actually just
wrote a little script.
And it did it in
a really nice way.
You can also write user-defined
functions inside a BigQuery.
So you can write JavaScript
instead of BigQuery,
in case your JavaScript
skills are a little bit better
than your SQL skills.
Another one that you can do
there that I find super fun
is-- like, if you're doing
anything with parsing JSON,
it's way easier to parse and
manipulate JSON with JavaScript
than it is with SQL.
So you can write little
query functions to do that.
MARK MANDEL: I don't
know Node very well.
And we're talking about
different Node versions.
Like you said, Apps Script
is moving to the V8 runtime.
And on App Engine, it was
moving from, like, 8 to 10
or something.
Why would I want to change
the different versions of Node
that I'd be using?
Why do I care as a developer?
MYLES BORINS: One
thing I could advise
to people who are
listening, if they
want to learn more about this--
there's a talk that I
gave called "The Hilarious
Misadventures of
Being a Platform
Downstream from your
Language" that digs
into this a little bit.
But the shorter version is,
Node conflates the concept
of an API and a runtime.
And it embeds
something called V8.
So V8 is the JavaScript engine
from the Chrome browser.
It's part of the
Chromium Project.
It's its own open
source project.
And V8 gets embedded in a whole
bunch of different places.
So when we're talking
about Apps Script,
the new version is based on V8.
When we're talking about those
user-defined function stuff,
V8 is what's executing
the JavaScript.
So V8 is a JavaScript
virtual machine.
And it gets embedded
in different places--
Chromium being one of them
and Node being one of them.
We embed V8.
When we execute your
JavaScript code,
we're handing it off to that VM.
And it's executing it
and doing stuff with it.
But with Node, it
executes your code.
But it's not just executing
arbitrary JavaScript.
It's executing it with
very specific semantics.
Like, when you use Require,
for example, that is a Nodism.
That's an API that we
created for module loading.
And when you use
something like FS,
that's not this standardized
API for File System work
that runs everywhere.
It is a Node-specific API.
So Node itself is
that combination
of a runtime and an API surface.
And when we talk about
the different versions,
like Node 8 versus Node 10, one
of the biggest and most obvious
differences is that 10 has a
newer version of the 8 in it.
MARK MANDEL: Gotcha.
MYLES BORINS: Because
it came out later.
And us updating V8 is a
[INAUDIBLE] major change
for all sorts of
different reasons.
I gave another talk
called "Node.js Versions--
How do they Work?--
which digs into that.
But essentially, it's a
breaking change for us
to upgrade V8 inside of Node.
So when you're on an older
version of Node, like Node 8,
you're using an older version
of the virtual machine.
So it may not have all the
same language features.
I think one of the ones
that's in 10 that isn't in 8
is, like, array.includes, maybe.
There's a couple of them.
The JavaScript language
is standardized.
And there's new features
added on a yearly basis.
So a new version of Node is
likely to have new features.
Like, Node 8, for example,
introduced async await,
which is a new way of handling
asynchronicity, which I can
babble about for a long time.
MARK MANDEL: Ha!
MYLES BORINS: But
Node 10, for example,
comes with a whole bunch of
optimizations to async await.
So the same async await
code will run, like,
20% faster in Node 10 than
in Node 8, because when
it came out in Node 8, it was
still a relatively new feature.
That's the different
versions of Node.
But then there's also all
those different versions
of V8, which introduce
the new features.
And when we upgrade
V8 in Node, we
get those new features in
Node, which then in turn
requires us to update some
of our APIs to reflect that.
So we're in the
process, for example,
of introducing a whole bunch
of new promise-based APIs.
Because most of our APIs are
traditionally callback-based
and-- more specifically--
Node callback based, which
is a very specific way
of writing callback code.
But if you want to use async
await, you want promises.
So like, for example,
in Node 8, we
have this new API
called util.promisify.
So you could take any
API that was written
using a callback-based API.
We turn it into a
promise-based API for you.
But one of the things
that we can do,
as a runtime, because we're
directly interfacing with V8,
is we can call the underlying
mechanisms of creating promises
in V8 itself.
So we can actually remove,
like, one promise and a couple
stack frames by
doing it this way.
So if you use our
util.promisify function
to turn your callback APIs
into promise-based APIs,
it'll be more efficient
than if you just
wrapped it in a promise.
But people can also just
write promise-based APIs.
There's lots of
different ways to do it.
To your original question
of why that matters--
really, it comes down to what
API surface you want to do
and what language features
you want available.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
JON FOUST: I'm actually quite
interested in Cloud Functions.
So I'm hoping that
we can actually
sit down together and
hash out some Cloud
Functions for gaming.
MYLES BORINS: Yeah-- absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MYLES BORINS: I
think for gaming,
too, depending on
what you're doing,
there's a lot of
interesting uses
for Cloud Functions in general.
And I think it'd be
cool to get down and--
similar to what I
was talking about,
where there isn't a huge
difference between functions
and apps and containers--
there are subtle differences.
So figuring out those
subtle differences
tend to be, like, how
you can figure out
which of those
shapes is the most
appropriate for the problem
space you're solving.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
Before we run away today,
is there anything special
that you want to plug?
Are you going anywhere?
Are you announcing
anything?-- anything
you haven't covered
today that you
want to make sure we
mention before we finish up?
MYLES BORINS: Well,
the merger, we're
hoping to land
officially and legally,
March 11, at the Open Source
Leadership Summit-- fingers
crossed.
I would encourage
people-- hey, there's
a whole bunch of
organizations that you
can volunteer for, donate to, to
help people get into technology
who are from traditionally
marginalized or
underrepresented groups-- so
groups like Black Girls Code
or Script Ed or Girls Who Code.
There's a list.
We should come up with
a bunch and put it
at the end of this podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
MYLES BORINS: But
I, for one, love
to spend my time doing
lots of different things.
It is not that hard to squeeze
in a little bit of time
to volunteer for
these organizations
or squeeze out a little bit
of money to help support them.
The world's not going
to change by themselves.
So put some time in.
JON FOUST: This is
great, because I actually
teach to a program that
functions in the same fashion,
targeting those marginalized
and underrepresented groups.
So this is definitely a
awesome thing to hear.
MARK MANDEL:
Awesome-- well, Myles,
thank you so much for joining
us today and telling us
all about Node.js and
all the fun things.
MYLES BORINS: Whoo!
Thank you for having me.
This is a lot of fun.
Hopefully, we can do
it again sometime.
Maybe 2021-- I'll pencil it in.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Always a pleasure.
JON FOUST: So thanks,
Myles, for joining us.
And hopefully,
we'll hear from you
in the near future on the
many cool things you're doing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah-- always
a pleasure to talk to Myles.
Getting stuck into our
question of the week, though,
I get to ask you tough
questions, which is fun too.
I hear you've been
having lots of fun
connecting Google Cloud APIs
to work within the Unity game
engine.
I think that's not
as easy as it sounds.
How have you managed
to get this to work?
JON FOUST: So recently,
I've been using
a lot of Pub/Sub and Translate.
And in order to get those APIs
working, what you actually
have to do is-- if you're using
Visual Studio as your editor
for Unity, what you do is you
download the NuGet package.
And it will download a series
of libraries on your computer.
And you would actually
have to locate those files
and move them over to a plugin
folder in your Unity project's
root folder.
Once you do that, you
have to create this link--
that XML file-- that
actually loads all
these references on startup.
Because just download
the NuGet packages
won't really help
you, because Unity
looks for those dependencies
and those references and all
those assemblies that you need
to load up every single time
that you start Unity.
And if your project cannot have
a file that points to those,
then it won't start up.
So that's a great option
to help you get started.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet-- and
that's the NuGet package
for the Google Cloud libraries?
JON FOUST: Yes-- you
can use any NuGet
package that has a supported
C-sharp client library.
MARK MANDEL: Oh nice--
very, very cool.
Well, that's great too.
Before we wrap up today,
Jon, where are you going?
Doing anything fun and
exciting in the near future?
JON FOUST: Yeah, so I'll
be at GDC next month.
I'll be at Cloud
Next in two months.
I'll be at ECGC, what
will be really fun.
And I will also
be at Vector 2019.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, very nice--
I like Vector.
It's a shame that I
won't be there this year.
But yeah-- so I think we're
going to be at the same places.
I will also be at GDC,
representing [INAUDIBLE]
and doing all sorts
of good stuff too.
Come check out the Google booth.
We're part of that.
Cloud Next-- we'll
be there as well.
I just got told that we will
have a space on the show
floor for the podcast.
So if you come into Cloud Next,
definitely swing by and say,
hello.
And I'll also be at East
Coast Games Conference,
presenting as well--
awesome.
Well, Jon, thank you
so much for joining me
on the podcast today.
JON FOUST: Yeah,
it's been a pleasure.
And I can't wait to join many,
many episodes in the future.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent-- and
thank you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]